-Our next guest
is a Tony-nominated
and Emmy Award-winning actress
you know
from films such as "The Truman
Show" and "Legally Blonde"
and shows such as "The Practice"
and "Two and a Half Men."
She's currently starring
in "The Stand In,"
which is in select theaters,
on demand, and on digital now.
Please welcome to the show
Holland Taylor, everybody.
How are you, Holland?
-I'm thrilled to be here.
I can't believe I've never
been on your show.
I'm so glad to see you this way.
-I know. I am both thrille
that you're finally here
and heartbroken
it's not in person.
It has been a very long time
since I saw you in person,
and that time was in an airport.
And while I feel you were happ
to see me,
you were far happier
to see my dog.
-Well, as a matter of fact
I just found out
you're on Instagram.
Because up until now,
I've been following your dog
You're also a presence.
-Yeah, she's got a real
social-media following.
This is a video that you
and Sarah Paulson took,
right, that we're gonna show
-Yes, I believe so.
The fastest tail wagger
in history.
-Here it is. I mean,
obviously she's fan of yours
Look how Frisbee reacted.
-Hello, hello.
Hello. Hello. Hi.
Oh, my goodness.
Hi.
-[ Laughs ]
When I told her you were
coming on tonight,
she waved the tail, knocked over
a glass of water.
It was a mess.
-You know, we actually
go to that page
and look at pictures of he
every so often.
Very soothing.
She's so darling.
She's the most delicious dog
-She's going to be so happ
to hear this,
because ever since we had kids
she feel like she's not gettin
this level of attention.
-My favorite picture of he
is when she's on the --
it's from behind the couch, an
you just see her head just tilt.
Beautiful big room.
-You and Sarah just got a do
through this time
that I think a lot of people
wisely have chosen
canine companionship
during this difficult year
-Yes, it's wonderful.
There's a dog park right
catty-corner from our house.
And most of the dogs
being walked there
are new to that family.
They're puppies and young dogs
and they have been rescue --
They're almost all rescue dogs
And it's a thing in
this pandemic, I'm sure,
all over the country.
There's lots of new puppies.
And not only that,
but these young dogs
have had an unusual amount
of time with their parents
because most people are home
So, it's a great beginning for
millions and millions of dogs.
-Did you guys become fast
friends, you and the dog?
Did you take to each other
immediately?
-Oh, yes.
Not as darling as Frisbee
in a way
'cause she has
her standoffish ways.
She's a mixed bag,
as we all are.
-Very fair.
You've had a lot
going on this year,
which is a strange thing to have
at a time when you also can'
go out and promote it in person.
You have this film "Hollywood"
with Ryan Murphy,
the "Bill & Ted" movie.
Have you enjoyed not having to
leave the house for press,
or have you found it difficult
-Not really.
First of all, I mean, it's bee
a frightening year, hasn't it?
I mean, we've all been
in an odd emotional state.
And so you retreat to your home.
Well, you have to stay
in your home.
And it should feel safe,
of course.
You have to go on talk shows
and you have to do
a lot of press.
I've had like five things have
opened -- or five or six things.
And to be in your house
seeking safety and comfort
and then having to
get your slap on
and appear on television
is a very strange experience
'cause there's no place safe
Also, I never wear makeup at all
during this whole year,
except when I'm doing
something like this.
So I put makeup on
and I see myself,
and I look like, you know,
an ancient hooker
still working in Vegas.
It's a shock from
what I usually --
-As long as you're
still working.
That's the important thing
-I'm working, baby.
I'm about to go to work
on something, too.
I'm gonna be working in
Pittsburgh for like six weeks.
That's gonna be something
during this pandemic.
-That's great and, you know,
obviously very exciting.
Another thing that was exciting,
and I know it's sort of
put on pause now,
you played Ann Richards
in a play called "Ann."
That was your idea.
And you were about to do it in
California for the first time.
Is that --
Of the roles you've played
does that one hold
a special place in your heart?
-That one really, you know
it wasn't a job.
It was a mission.
I didn't think of it
like an idea.
It really flooded over me
truly like an inspiration,
the only thing that ever
happened like that in my life.
I was in my 60s.
So that's really remarkable.
And I created --
It was a very long process
years in the creation,
and I did it
all over the country
and on Broadway, certainly
And it was, you know --
I wanted that great
American patriot to be known
and still around to inspir
people, because she does.
So that is my greatest
achievement of my life.
That is for sure, and I don'
think of it as a job.
-I know you were lucky enoug
to get know Ann Richards,
who was the governor of Texas.
And you also then had to do,
I think when you decided thi
was a play you were going to do,
a great amount of research
on her.
-Oh, the research
is where I got it all.
And for some reason,
I don't know,
everybody around her felt
that I could do this.
And the doors were opened.
And I've become
very good friends
with lot of her closest people
who were friends
and also part
of her administration,
one and the same.
And I really deep dive
for about three years
before I put pen to paper.
And I just hoped that if I
created like a hologram of her
some of the inspiration woul
come along with it, and it did
And so when people see me
on the street
and they compliment me on that
it's so great
'cause they don't say,
"You were so great."
They saw, "I saw your play
I was so inspired.
She was so great."
That's exactly what I wanted
So, I was very lucky.
-Did you do it --
Did it premiere in Texas?
Was that the first place
you did it?
-Yes, we did it
in Galveston, Texas,
the first time
at the opera house there.
And we did it at the Paramount
in Austin.
Then we did it at the Empire
in San Antonio.
And then we did it at
the great Shubert in Chicago
which is great theater town.
And then we did it
at the Kennedy Center.
That was a great invitation.
That was truly thrilling
on the main stage there.
And then we did it
at Lincoln Center.
-Were the stakes higher for yo
doing it in Texas
for the first time,
the place where people
were maybe the most familiar
with her, obviously?
-I was terrified.
And I got much better.
I mean, I worked with
a dialect person, always.
And I was also constantly
refining the play
and working on it.
So I would learn a great dea
every run.
And I also had to
always shorten it,
because you have to
keep it very tight
as we headed towards Broadway.
And so when I opened it,
I was terrified
'cause I was opening it
in her backyard.
And the play started,
and I literally heard a gasp
in the audience.
And that's Paul Huntley's wig,
I think, got that.
And it was open sesame
from there on.
For some reason they just said
"Yeah, we're buying this."
-That's so exciting.
And that's such wonderful
feedback to get from fans.
I also want to ask, becaus
you had such a diverse career,
you know, a storied career
that's ranged everywhere
from drama to comedy.
Is there something specific that
people most approach you about
when they see you on the street?
-"Legally Blonde" is probabl
the most because of that line.
"If you're gonna let
one stupid prick ruin" --
I can't even say it.
That wonderful line.
"If you let one stupid prick
ruin your life,
you're not the girl
I thought you were."
Something like that.
People love that.
-It is certainly
a multigenerational
good piece of advice.
-It was a great role.
It's wonderful to play
a great teacher, which she was
-Well, it's been such an honor
to have you here.
I really do appreciate
you giving us the time.
And thank you so much.
-It was my pleasure.
And would you please tell
Frisbee she's a very good girl
-I might just play the tap
'cause it's so much better
coming from you
than it is from me.